remember I said you can make them you
know big small positive negative one
thing you will notice if what you want
is not just one of them on both an a.m.
and a GM you can't make one positive and
the other negative they call three
different signs we know exactly why we
drew a diagram and we colored it can you
tell me why they can't be different
signs good good so if they are different
signs right one positive one negative
one positive or vice-versa
okay if you're going to get an a.m. no
problem okay that means you're at that
transition right where this is virtually
the series started sequence started one
way and it transitions to the other
that's fine okay but you cannot possibly
find a geometric mean right at least not
with the numbers we know about okay
because this alternating thing is
alternating thing it has to have like if
I'm gonna have a number it pops it in
the middle like and I've got a negative
and a positive
it can't be positive because then I have
two positives in right and it can't be
negative because I'm gonna have to
[ __ ] around it's not gonna work okay
so here's my simple example now I'm
going to get you to UM I hope you've
worked out you're a man GM now I want
you to look at your two numbers if you
have some we'd own umbers like um like
SERDES in there or something like that I
need you to find me a decimal for those
because what we're about to do is we're
about to compare these two numbers
together and certs
are famously difficult to compare to
each other cuz you can't you know
acceptable so if you got some thirds in
there like I almost did please get me a
decimal value just none zero is fine I
just went well actually maybe one
depending on the size of your numbers
just so you can tell the numbers apart
all right now here's what I'm gonna ask
you to do I want you to tell me about
the am the a.m. and the absolute value
or what we call the magnitude or the
size of the GM I'm just going to for a
moment forget that Brennan exists
and I'm just interested in the positive
case okay now here's I want you to do I
want you to look at your AMG and when I
punked you I want you or sellout which
one is bigger okay because you all have
different numbers right do all the
different numbers which one is bigger
I'm gonna count to three you say either
a.m. or Jimmy you ready
okay one two three and every single one
of you but you will pick different
numbers don't you okay now what's going
on here what's going on here this is
kind of the equivalent of if you are you
know in the Junior School and you're
first learning at the angles of a
triangle and you know all-knowing person
up the front says okay cut out a
triangle for me any triangle you like
different triangles and then rip it into
three pieces so you have it three angles
and then you reassemble it to make
something like this like ripped paper
paper paper and you put your three
angles together and magically they form
a straight angle 180 degrees okay now
you know why you know what if you if you
didn't do that I'm sorry you had
approach other maybe we cannot know but
we can reenact it down you know why this
always happens and I know why this
always happens okay
in fact the a is always greater than the
GM except the one case they can't be
equal that you have a think we'll get
there in a second I'll let you think
about in what single case the AM and GM
can be actually equal to each other it's
bit weird but for all intents and
purposes that M is always bigger than
the GM okay this is called this result
is called unimaginably it is called the
am GM inequality inequalities and proofs
regarding inequalities one of these hot
of three new topics that we will address
in well in
but this is so easy to grasp now I'm
going to show you in two ways that um it
just be a crime button I'll show you
okay so I need some more space which
please draw a circle form this circle
here I've drawn a diameter in there
we've been dealing with our a pair of
nobodies time like an A and a B and then
I want a number in the middle okay so
what I want to do is I'm gonna take this
diameter and I'm going to make an A and
a B out of it now you can pick any point
you like to divide up this diameter and
if I make a circle of arbitrary size I
can make a and B as large or as small as
I like okay but just for our intensive
efforts you I'm going to put a cuz um at
least for now
it's probably easier conceptually to
think a vamp series that get bigger
seriously get smaller sequences that get
smaller I know different okay but if
you're thinking about growing that's
kind of a helpful metaphor to have your
head okay so what I'm gonna do is I'm
just going to divide up this number you
can divide a slightly to the left of the
center and I'm going to label each of
I'm gonna label each of these new
intervals then I thought I'm gonna call
this one eight and I'm gonna call this
one
B okay so here are my two numbers here
are the the ends or the first and third
terms in my sequence and what I'm
interested in is geometrically see what
I did there
geometrically what do the a.m. & GM
represent in relation to these things
okay what do the MGM represent in
relation to these two lengths now we're
going to start with the am the am is the
easiest okay I already know the formula
for the a.m. is in this context it's
going to be a plus B divided by two
right now
a plus B divided by two that length that
length is already on my diagram is it
not what is it it's a distance right
it's a distance it's going to be the
radius right um even though that's a
point there that divides not the
intervals are the actual numbers I'm
interested in okay so therefore you
color
okay the a.m. is well it's any radius on
the circle
it's the arithmetic mean is the average
between a and V that's where it is
that's what it looks like okay now
what's interesting by the way is that
see I'm in this circle and I put a and B
there what would happen if I made a
really really tiny and be much bigger
than portion of circle how did that
change the a.m. answer it wouldn't
because as you've been this nervous for
walk you're making this number bigger so
that midpoint is still gonna stay put
it's still gonna be in our circle the
range now the GM GM is a bit harder to
see I'm going to give you a construction
that doesn't look very intuitive like
why are you doing that but it'll come
out why see this um this break was made
in the diameter let's try a vertical
line through there that sounds
ridiculous now it's very important that
it's vertical or more importantly that
it's a right angle because if it's a
right angle
I now can use some of my circle
properties and I can know some things
about this chord that I've just drawn
okay for instance since this is a line
from the center to the center and
intersects with the chord at right
angles okay what does that mean about
the relationship between these two
intervals here they're equal like
they're right there are lots of ways to
say this particular property line from
the center perpendicular to a chord
bisects the chord or the perpendicular
bisector of a chord passes through the
center it's got like a million versus
right so within the Luminess okay now I
want to be able to talk about these like
so I'm just gonna give it a name briefly
I'm just gonna call this s this is X
because you told me they were equal now
that I have four lengths on here a B X
and X they're not chords that they're
part of chords right we have a name for
this it starts with an i we don't use it
all that frequently when you divide up
these are called intercepts it's a bit
confusing as we
we use it to search for other meanings
in other contexts but this is an
intercept of this chord this is another
one there's another other four of them
okay what do we know about intercepts of
intersecting chords on a circle tell me
what you know about them
we know that their products are equal
whether the products come from if I draw
like any pair of lines to make some
similar triangles here okay I'm gonna
get a ratio relationship and then you
just cross multiply and you get products
okay so in this case I can say x times X
that's the product of the intercepts on
this chord is equal to a times B that's
the product to you tips on this port
right x squared equals a big I might as
well put the reason for that because not
high and also you know HotList remember
when we come back to this later
where'd that come from right the
products of intercepts on what they see
they're intersecting cords those two
products they're going to be identical
environment okay now you can see he's
right there isn't it
the DM is staring us in the face because
at least in this diagram because X is a
distance I'm only going to get one of
the geums that's okay no big deal x
equals the GM that's that length there
you see I don't need to call it X
anymore right this vertical distance
because it's a core that's been sliced
in half we call it a semi coin just like
you have a semi circle is a circle
that's been sliced in half
and for some reason someone decided to
course fees that are sliced in half
hemispheres I don't know whatever
English anyway that they're half accord
that semi cord is the geometric mean
okay all right now I wondered any of you
can see why this must be true why the am
GM inequality has to be true because
look at the diagram is it popping
that you well yeah basically the cordon
is the midpoint of the circle the am the
energy okay so you're getting two you're
getting to my next point which is with
that one case where the equal it's fine
we'll revisit it okay Jackie and before
do yes now that can I say that again
because that's so crucial and it's we're
not used to thinking in these terms
right but it's a great thing to notice
cuz it's very profound right the a.m.
it's it's on values locked in in this
circle it's the radius no matter where
you put aim where you put B you're
always going to get the radius okay now
we said that this line here it has to be
perpendicular right you can't just draw
any of which way it's perpendicular here
now what happens is I move a and B as I
move that point on the G will get
smaller it can get smaller you can also
get longer but it has a maximum right
the longest the GM can possibly be is
here if it's also if it is also half of
the diameter the radius right because as
soon as we go past there if we're going
this way the GM starts to get smaller
again do you see that okay so the GM is
strictly always because it's inside
inside a circle it's always going to be
less then now gets a red ass point and
Jack did mention it as well for why
there is one and one only case where the
g-man am in fact are equal to each other
what I know about a and B if a.m. and GM
are equal it means that the same time
pop right let me just draw a small one
now yeah okay there's my
there's my diameter okay there's the
center here's the a.m. okay
the only possible way I can make the GM
the same is if I put that right down the
middle okay but what does that mean
about MB and V are also the radius so
for instance if you have a series like
oh I don't know 10 10 okay the mean
between those two arithmetic Li is 20
divided by 2 which is 10 or
geometrically 10 times 10 which is 100
take square root still 10 not
particularly interesting which is why
the most important thing about this is
that the M is pretty much in all the
interesting places bigger than the
geophone okay are you happy with that